he's meeting the secretaries of state
and defense topher bennett's agenda is
stopping u.s efforts to restore a
nuclear deal with iran he's going to
meet u.s president joe biden at the
white house later hadal abdulhamid has
more from west jerusalem on what to
expect from the visit
he was once a us citizen son of
immigrants who settled on the west coast
now naftali bennett is going to the
white house as prime minister of israel
a key ally of the united states but
whose relations with democrats in the
u.s were somewhat fraught during the
premiership of his predecessor benjamin
netanyahu it's been very clear from the
beginning that the goals of both naftali
bennett and foreign minister yaya lapid
were to rebuild the bipartisan nature of
the relationship that they thought was
lacking during the 12 years under
netanyahu who really focused on the
republican party also top of the agenda
is iran
israel opposing efforts made by the
biden administration to return to the
2015 agreement which biden's predecessor
pulled out from and after the targeting
of an israeli-managed ship in the gulf
of oman bennett is trying to bring about
an international consensus when it comes
to retaliation but gone are the days of
trump when an israeli prime minister
appeared to be able to dictate the
middle east foreign policy of the white
house
the biden administration favoring a
two-state solution when it comes to
dealing with the israeli-palestinian
conflict bennett has already scored a
point with the biden administration the
u.s consulate here in occupied east
jerusalem that deals with palestinians
was shot by the trump administration
there was talk about reopening it but at
the request of israel the state
department has shelved that plan at
least for now time to allow the new
israeli government to pass the budget in
the knesset by november necessary for
the ruling coalition to survive look the
the democratic administration is fully
aware of the very delicate nature of
israel's coalition and the fact that
basically the israel's prime minister is
is
trading on eggs all the time and
therefore he has to be very cautious
very careful
since bennett took office the u.s state
department has made statements against
house demolitions and illegal jewish
settlement expansions in the occupied
palestinian territory which bennett has
been an advocate of since his entry in
political life
these are good steps but not enough it's
lip service biden should say the only
solution is to end the occupation
because the image of israel today in the
world is one of apartheid ethnic
cleansing and racism it's very
uncomfortable for the us to be
associated with that
opinions are changing in the us when it
comes to israel bennett's visit comes at
a time when progressives within the
democratic party are pushing to
recalibrate the relationship between the
two countries
calls for conditioning military aid to
israel and open criticism have moved
from the fringe to the floors of
congress
with that in mind bennett's toughest
challenge is to convince the american
public that he is the face of a
government which is inclusive in more
than just a name
hamid al-jazeera west jerusalem